right now in australia the construction
industry is
booming which also means all architects
designers
and everybody in that profession is
extremely busy
and looking to hire today we're talking
about why a grad
might be the absolute best hire in 2020
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
like i mentioned already today we're
talking about why a graduate of
architecture
or potentially a building designer or
any form of other graduate
might be the absolute best hire right
now in 2020
we're going to do this in a bit of a
different unique way today i guess
and it's definitely something i haven't
done before on this channel
so if it doesn't work out i apologize i
will try and make this
as absolutely best as possibly as i can
anyway we're going to be looking at this
from the director's point of view
their usual concerns of hiring a grad
and also having that grad
and what the value they bring to that
team as somebody who used to be
in this position only a few years ago i
know exactly what it's like to be
hunting for a job
to be going to all sorts of different
interviews being asked a million
questions
and not actually being seen for the true
value that you may potentially provide
anyway without further ado let's get
into today's video
okay so let's slide across a little bit
e make some room for bradley and his
very first appearance on the show today
welcome bradley thanks for having me
dave as the business owner and director
my concerns are usually about your
performance so today i want to get
started with a few of those concerns
okay sure go on all right so first of
all my main concern for i guess
everybody out there watching and for you
as well today bradley
is the simple fact that you don't know
our programs and
you definitely don't know our standards
yeah this is probably true in a pretty
valid point
so that's all good but you have to
remember i was raised with technology
for the last 25 plus years of my life i
have
spent every waking moment learning about
tech
so i'm the best candidate and one of the
quickest learners to be able to learn
any software that you throw at me yeah
okay you make a valid point
but as a new grad you're actually going
to cost me a lot more money to employ
then it's going to cost me to employ
somebody with a little bit of experience
potentially that doesn't have the
qualifications that you have
yeah but i'm also very very cheap to
employ you have to remember that as a
grad i'm more than likely going to be
putting in so much overtime
to make up for the things and the errors
i've made during the working week
that are actually in the long run going
to make you some money
so all in all it isn't the worst
decision
that you have to pay me a little bit
more for me to do
a lot more than anticipated what about
all the staff resources i have to bring
in
to actually train you to do this job
properly yeah but what about all the
things i'm going to teach you and your
staff members
you have to remember that i've just
spent the last five years dedicating
my entire waking life to learning about
the profession
i've learned everything that's up and
coming and i'm
able to teach you and all of the staff
these skills that i've acquired
so having me on board is actually going
to be super beneficial
to everybody in the firm yeah okay i'd
actually be lying i said that wasn't a
good comeback that's a pretty good
comeback keep going
plus as a grad i'm well aware of the
fact that i'm probably going to be
working on the most basic
jobs that you have in this firm that
doesn't mean i want to be working on
them
but it does mean your other senior staff
members won't be working on them
which means the guys that don't want to
work on them their staff
morale is going to be so much higher by
having me here
and taking those little jobs away from
them
okay so let's say goodbye to bradley for
a minute
and actually talk back to you guys now
so i guess
one of the main things that you have to
consider and be concerned about
when interviewing or being interviewed
is actually
bringing value to the team or bringing
value to the firm
standing on your own two feet with a
good portfolio is a good start
but being able to actually bring some
sort of value
to this firm and this team is incredibly
incredibly important that i can't stress
enough
i think from somebody hiring and being
on the other end of the table for the
first time ever
it was very difficult on my end to be
able to understand where these people
came from
but being able to isolate them from
their portfolios and
their enthusiasm in an interview
actually made it
a lot easier to be able to select
somebody to join the team
by having a good portfolio with
potentially just abstract ideas versus
solid construction knowledge and having
great enthusiasm to learn
to be wanting to be part of the team and
knowing a little bit about the firm and
the interview you're walking into
is incredibly valuable one of my
personal favorite interview questions is
what kind of hobbies do you have
and that's simply for me to fish out
what kind of other skill sets
you might be bringing to the table so
personally for me i ran all sorts of
different businesses
and loved photography videography social
media
all of that before i got into the
profession of architecture
so from my end i actually brought in
some sort of
marketing background into what was
previously
a non-marketing industry so if this
professional that you're interviewing
has some sort of
i guess background hobby where they like
to spend their time making youtube
videos
either taking photos taking videos doing
something creative
that might be able to be backtracked
into the firm
is an exceptional asset to have and a
great answer to be looking for
most of the time you'll get the simple
answer like i enjoy running or i enjoy
sport which are good answers it means
they get out they interact with the
community
however if you're looking for somebody
to actually bring value to the firm
you want to be looking for people that
have more than
your standard sport answers in these
interviews
one more thing to be mindful of is grads
are actually pretty thankful to get a
job straight out of uni or college
depending on where you're watching this
video
they have a tendency to be thankful for
that position
for a very long time it means they're
probably going to stick around in that
firm
for anywhere between three to five years
as a basic graduate
whilst there's other grads that are
extremely valuable to the firm
and are shown that they're valuable to
the firm in some way shape or form
being a financial remuneration or just
constant positive reinforcement
they might actually stick around for a
lifetime so that grad
may be the best hire you've had in a
very long time
yes i know you're not investing in a
very
knowledgeable educated technical
construction detailer but that's
probably not what you're looking for at
the start either
so if you're out there hiring a grad
these are some fundamental things that
you need to keep in the back of your
mind
because grads aren't just you're simple
easy to get
going and chuck them to do the basic
jobs nobody wants
even though most of them aware that
they're going to do that you don't
really
need to do that because these guys have
more skills
and are trained to be able to do things
that you probably haven't even thought
about
anyway that's all for me today guys
thanks so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below help this video with
the algorithm
and if you want to see more of my
content smash that subscribe button
and as always i will see you next monday